From WBEZ Chicago, it is another hour of high-minded radio broadcasting distributed by Public Radio International, which is to say, it's This American Life , which is to say, hello. It's post time.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，又是新的一小时高水准广播节目，由公共广播国际公司分发，也就是说，这是《美国生活》节目，也就是说，你好，比赛时间到了。
It's opening day at Arlington Racetrack just outside Chicago. And maybe because of the rain, maybe because not that many adults can come out to the track in the middle of a weekday, there are just four guys, regulars, in one of the rooms reserved for regulars. Four guys in a spacious room with what have to be 20 television monitors.
芝加哥郊外的阿灵顿赛马场开赛了。也许是因为下雨，也许是因为工作日期间没那么多成年人能来到现场，在为常客预留的房间里只有四个人。四个人待在一个宽敞的房间里，里面大概有 20 台电视监视器。
The way we measure these horses is very mathematical and very scientific.
我们衡量这些马匹的方式非常数学化，也非常科学。
This is Roger Vice. Really, that's his name, Mr. Vice. A guy who makes his living betting on the horses. The kind of disciplined guy who gives the impression that maybe his goatee and his clothes never get messy.
这位是罗杰·维斯。真的，他就叫这个名字，维斯先生。他靠赛马博彩为生。他是个极其自律的人，给人一种他的山羊胡和衣服永远不会变脏的印象。
What I do is, each race-- you see all these marks on my program? These are a tracking of where the horse was on the turn. OK? So I keep track of where every horse was on that turn. I keep track of the wind-- the direction, the velocity. I time every race.
我做的是，每一场比赛——你看到我参赛指南上的这些标记了吗？这些是对马匹转弯处位置的追踪。对吧？所以我追踪每一匹马在那个转弯处的位置。我追踪风向——方向、速度。我记录每一场比赛的时间。
Mr. Vice shows me a product called Thoro-Graph which is basically a computerized analysis and printout of speed ratings and histories for each horse, and a cheat sheet that he made for himself with other data which gets surprisingly precise and technical.
维斯先生向我展示了一种叫 Thoro-Graph 的产品，基本上就是对每匹马的速度评级和历史记录进行的计算机分析和打印件，还有他自己制作的备忘单，上面有其他数据，精确且技术含量惊人。
So if a horse is three wide, you think about the laws of physics, the horse that's three wide is running a greater distance. OK? We factor that in mathematically.
所以如果一匹马在外侧三马位处，你考虑一下物理定律，在外侧跑的马跑的距离更长。对吧？我们从数学上把这个因素考虑进去。
We disagree a lot. In fact, all of these guys disagree with me most of the time.
我们经常有分歧。事实上，所有这些人大部分时间都不同意我的观点。
Mike is retired from the Post Office, and his table is the messiest one in the room. Three of the guys here on opening day, Craig, Jeff, and Mr. Vice, all do this very technical analysis to make their bets. Mike is the outcast.
迈克是从邮局退休的，他的桌子是房间里最乱的一张。开赛当天在这里的三个人，克雷格、杰夫和维斯先生，都用这种非常专业的技术分析来下注。迈克是个异类。
I have my own system. My system-- I find that betting favorites, in the long run, you end up losing money. Most of my horses are in the 20, 30 to one shots range. So I don't bet a lot of races here every day.
我有我自己的系统。我的系统——我发现从长远来看，押注热门马匹最终会亏钱。我的马大多是 20 到 30 倍赔率的冷门马。所以我每天在这里不赌太多场次。
Betting only long shots makes him really different from Jeff, who puts a lot of bets out there looking for a small percentage return. And from Craig, who plays more favorites, and who overhears Mike describing his system to me and then turns to me and says, you ever read the book One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest? That's Mike's system. And in the eighth race, I get to see Mike's system in action.
只赌冷门马让他和杰夫截然不同，杰夫会下很多注以寻求小额回报。他也和克雷格不同，克雷格更倾向于投热门马，他在听到迈克向我描述他的系统后转头对我说，你看过《飞越疯人院》那本书吗？那就是迈克的系统。在第八场比赛中，我亲眼看到了迈克的系统是如何运作的。
Well, this is my best bet of the day is Intrinsic Worth in the eighth.
嗯，我今天最看好的是第八场里的“内在价值”。
And why? Why is that your best bet?
为什么？为什么那是你最看好的？
I like the trainer. Honestly, but I might not even bet on him because he might be too short for me.
我喜欢那个驯马师。老实说，但我甚至可能不会押他，因为赔率对他来说可能太低了。
The odds won't be good enough.
赔率不够好。
Right. If the odds are not good enough, I'm going to lay off the race.
对。如果赔率不够好，我就不参与这场比赛了。
We watch the race on the TV monitors. Intrinsic Worth is wearing the number five and comes out of the gate poorly.
我们在电视监视器上观看比赛。“内在价值”穿着五号，起跑表现不佳。
The five broke bad. Right now he's running-- where is he running, fifth? He's out of the picture right now. I'm sure he's running last.
五号起跑很差。现在他在跑——他在哪里？第五？他现在已经出局了。我敢肯定他在最后一名。
And then, to make a short story very short, in the final stretch number five comes in from 20 lengths back.
然后，长话短说，在最后冲刺阶段，五号从 20 个马位后追了上来。
Right now, it looks like--
现在看起来——
Look at this horse. The horse is flying. Here comes the five flying. If he broke bit, he's going to win the race.
看这匹马。这匹马在飞奔。五号飞过来了。如果他起跑好一点，他肯定能赢下这场比赛。
And then it's over.
然后比赛结束了。
See? There it is. The five, from 20 lengths back, won the race.
看到了吗？就是这样。五号，从 20 个马位后追赶上来，赢得了比赛。
Your horse?
你的马？
The horse that I told you. He looked like much the best in the race, and he was much the best. He went off at five to two, which means you get $7 back for $2 bets.
就是我跟你说的那匹。他看起来是比赛中最强的一匹，他也确实是最强的。他的赔率是二赔五，这意味着你押 2 美元可以赢回 7 美元。
Which for Mike was not even enough to place a bet. And this is why he and his system are taking a beating today. He picked the right horse. He was confident. But he didn't get long shot odds. So he didn't put in a bet, and he didn't make any money. These other guys in the same situation, they would have bet. They're like a group of scientists who all look at the same data and then all come to completely different conclusions, which when you think about it, is about as different from the way that regular scientists work as you can get.
这对于迈克来说甚至不够下注的门槛。这就是为什么他和他的系统今天惨败的原因。他选对了马。他很有信心。但他没有得到冷门的高赔率。所以他没下注，也没赚到钱。这里的其他人如果是同样的情况，他们会下注的。他们就像一群科学家，看着同样的数据却得出了完全不同的结论，当你仔细想想，这和普通科学家的工作方式简直大相径庭。
What I think's most interesting about horse racing is that it gives you a chance for analysis. You're analyzing a group of horses, a group of trainers, a group of jockeys, the patterns that the horses have run, and you make a decision. And every 25 minutes, there's a new decision to be made. And if you're right, you can make money with it.
我认为赛马最有趣的地方在于它为你提供了分析的机会。你在分析一群马、一群驯马师、一群骑师，分析这些马曾经跑过的模式，然后你做出决定。每 25 分钟，就有一个新的决定要做。如果你是对的，你就能从中赚钱。
Well, today on our program, people who are using the tools of analysis, the scientific reasoning of real science in settings where scientists don't really belong. It's fake science. We all do it every day in all sorts of situations. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in four acts, "Spook Science," "Government Science," "Beauty Science," and last, but not least, "Radio Science." Four acts of people tossing around questionable data, making logical jumps that they really should think twice about, in short, acting like you and me. And if you've got any question at all about the truth of that last statement, well, stay tuned.
嗯，今天我们的节目将介绍那些在科学家本不该涉足的领域里，使用分析工具和真正科学的逻辑推理的人们。这是伪科学。我们每天在各种情况下都在做这件事。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分四幕：“灵异科学”、“政府科学”、“美学科学”，最后但同样重要的是，“广播科学”。四幕讲述人们随意引用可疑数据、做出逻辑跳跃，而这些跳跃他们本该三思而后行，简而言之，就是表现得像你我一样。如果你对最后一句话的真实性有任何疑问，好吧，请保持收听。
Act One, Spook Science. Jake Warga heard of a group in Seattle that is trying to use whatever scientific methods it can find to hunt for ghosts. He tells this story.
第一幕，灵异科学。杰克·瓦加听说西雅图有一个组织试图利用所能找到的任何科学方法来寻找鬼魂。他讲述了这个故事。
I've been invited to spend the night in a cabin deep in the woods, no electricity, no phones, with a group of ghost hunters. They've been asked there by the owner who thinks it's haunted.
我受邀去森林深处的一间小屋过夜，那里没有电，没有电话，陪伴我的是一群捉鬼人。是房主请他们来的，她认为那里闹鬼。
There's three buildings, three or four buildings, on this campsite. The resident has experienced some things, and she sent me some pictures. There's a cemetery near the residence.
这个营地里有三四栋建筑。住户经历了一些事情，她给我发了一些照片。住宅附近有一个墓地。
Patricia Woolard is Vice President of AGHOST, which stands for Amateur Ghost Hunters of Seattle-Tacoma. Ross is the president.
帕特里夏·伍拉德是 AGHOST 的副总裁，全称是西雅图-塔科马业余捉鬼人协会。罗斯是总裁。
Ross and I are the only two people that really know the history of this place. And one of the cabins at one time housed a body for several months, someone who died, that was not able to be buried because she died in the winter.
罗斯和我是在场唯一真正了解这个地方历史的人。其中一间小屋曾存放过一具尸体好几个月，是一位去世的女性，因为死于冬天而无法下葬。
The location is an old mining camp going way back to the early 1900s. At one point, it was a Bible camp during the summer. And there were rumors of child abuse. And in the early '30s, a woman died of TB, but the ground was too hard to break for a grave. They decided to wait until first thaw. So they put the body in a small cabin on the property. They had her children take shifts and stay vigil by the body just in case she came back. They did this for over a month until the ground thawed and, I guess, it became clear she wasn't coming back.
这个地点是一个追溯到 20 世纪初的旧矿营。有一段时间，它在夏天是个圣经营。有传言说那里发生过虐待儿童的事。30 年代初，一名妇女死于肺结核，但土地太硬，无法挖掘坟墓。他们决定等到第一次解冻。所以他们把尸体放在了房产里的一间小屋里。他们让她的孩子们轮流看守，以防她回来。他们这样做了超过一个月，直到土地解冻，我想，很明显她不会回来了。
I've got them all labeled from EVP. So I have all my tape recorders. I have about three or four tape recorders in there with extra tapes. And then we have our meters case.
我给它们都贴上了 EVP 标签。我有我所有的录音机。我带了三四台录音机在里面，备有额外的磁带。然后我们有我们的仪表箱。
AGHOST's President, Ross Allison, is going over about seven silver cases he has loaded with electronic gear. Ghost hunters love gadgets. Luckily, Ross's day job is at a photo/electronics retailer.
AGHOST 的总裁罗斯·艾里森正在检查他装满电子设备的七个银色箱子。捉鬼人热爱小工具。幸运的是，罗斯的日常工作是在一家照相/电子零售商那里。
And our wireless infrared sensors.
还有我们的无线红外传感器。
So you believe in ghosts?
所以你相信鬼魂吗？
I would like to. There's a part of me that, yes, I do believe in ghosts. Inside of me, I really want to believe that there's something out there, that death is not the end. Being in this field and wanting to be able to pursue it in the correct manner, you do have to be skeptical. We basically just go in, document everything that's happened, and state our case on the website, and let you decide for yourselves. Well, could this place be haunted?
我愿意相信。我内心的一部分，是的，我相信鬼魂。在内心深处，我真的希望相信有某种东西存在，死亡并不是终点。在这个领域工作，并且希望以正确的方式去探索，你必须保持怀疑。我们基本上只是进去，记录下所发生的一切，把我们的案例放在网站上，然后让你自己做决定。那么，这个地方可能闹鬼吗？
This place is like a horror movie set of itself, complete with creaking doors and wind chimes. And just like in the movies, it's starting to get dark.
这个地方本身就像一部恐怖电影的布景，有吱吱作响的门和风铃。就像电影里一样，天开始黑了。
All right, as everybody gets ready, make sure they have a flashlight on them. Because again, there's not going to be any power. So it would be interesting to find out if we get any EMF readings up here. Because I don't even get cell phone reception here.
好了，大家准备好，确保每个人身上都有手电筒。因为再说一次，这里不会有任何电源。如果能在这里得到任何电磁场读数会很有趣。因为我在这里连手机信号都没有。
EMF, by the way, stands for electromagnetic field. Spirits are apparently energy that can be detected with devices that measure electricity in the air. The EMF detectors they're using are sold as devices for telling where the wires in your walls are. But cameras are the most popular ghost hunting tool because they can capture orbs. Orbs are the little circles of light that sometimes show up in photographs or videos. Most people think they're particles of dust or stray light hitting the lens. Ghost hunters believe they might be the energy of spirits. And most everyone is wearing a cassette recorder to record the voices of the dead. The theory is that deep in the background hiss of a recording hide unexplained voices. Basically, if I went out to a cemetery, started recording and asking questions out into the air that, upon playing back the tapes, really cranking up the silent spots, I should get responses.
顺便提一下，EMF 代表电磁场。幽灵显然是一种能量，可以通过测量空气中电力的设备检测到。他们使用的 EMF 探测器是作为检测墙内电线位置的设备出售的。但照相机是捉鬼人最受欢迎的工具，因为它们可以捕捉到“光球”。光球是照片或视频中偶尔出现的微小光圈。大多数人认为它们是灰尘颗粒或撞击镜头的杂散光。捉鬼人相信它们可能是灵体的能量。几乎每个人都戴着卡带录音机来记录死者的声音。理论是，在录音深沉的背景嘶嘶声中隐藏着无法解释的声音。基本上，如果我走进一个墓地，开始录音并向空气中提问，在回放磁带时，把安静的地方声音调大，我应该能得到回应。
Let's see. This one was when I got-- I was up by myself, and I asked out in the air, is anyone still here? And I get a response.
看看这个。这是我得到的一段——我当时一个人在上面，我向空气中问，还有人在吗？我得到了回应。
Is anyone still here?
还有人在吗？
I'm here.
我在这儿。
Is anyone still here?
还有人在吗？
I'm here.
我在这儿。
The voice is saying, I'm here.
那个声音在说，我在这儿。
Is anyone still here?
还有人在吗？
I'm here.
我在这儿。
What are you doing here?
你在这里做什么？
OK, we are hooking up a mike.
好了，我们正在连接麦克风。
I'm hooking up my microphone because I record everything that I say and do.
我正在连接我的麦克风，因为我记录我所说和所做的每一件事。
Stephanie is our psychic, but not like you might think. No crystal balls or late night TV commercials. She's studying for her real estate license. She's just a part of the group and sensing things is her role. We don't tell her about the history of the site.
斯蒂芬妮是我们的灵媒，但不是你可能想象的那样。没有水晶球或深夜电视广告。她正在学习房地产执照。她只是团队的一部分，感知事物是她的角色。我们没有告诉她这个地点的历史。
I do get the sense that somebody died on this property. But I haven't determined if it's by their choice, or if it's natural or--
我确实感觉到有人死在这个房产上。但我还没确定这是他们的选择，还是自然的，或者——
I'm waiting outside the small cabin, listening on a wireless mike I have on Stephanie. I try not to pee myself because they're in the cabin that has the body.
我在小屋外面等着，通过我给斯蒂芬妮戴的无线麦克风监听。我尽量不让自己吓尿，因为他们在存放尸体的小屋里。
And we don't mean you--
我们并不是说要你——
This door won't stay open.
这扇门关不上。
--any harm. I am sensing a very foul odor in this area. Very foul.
——受到任何伤害。我感觉到这个区域有一种非常难闻的气味。非常难闻。
Not now, but--
不是现在，但是——
No. Is there anyone here with us? Is there anything you'd like to say? But I still get that really foul odor in here. OK, I'm ready.
没有。这里有人和我们在一起吗？有什么你想说的吗？但我在这里还是闻到那种非常难闻的气味。好吧，我准备好了。
They leave the cabin and start up a path into the woods. Huge pine trees surround us.
他们离开小屋，沿着一条小路走进森林。巨大的松树环绕着我们。
I want to stop here please. You know what? I know this is really crazy. I totally got a vision of a body. That never happens to me. Like an actual body.
我想在这里停一下。你知道吗？我知道这很疯狂。我完全看到了一个尸体的幻象。这从未发生在我身上。就像一个真正的尸体。
She describes what she sees. Short woman with curly hair in the style of the 1930s. Later, going through old photos with the owner, Stephanie points to one photo. "Fern [? Killins," ?] it reads. That's her. That's the woman. It turns out that Fern is the woman who died of TB, whose body was left in that cabin for a month. Stephanie is confused about why she saw the body until she discovers, just around a bank of trees, the cemetery where Fern is buried.
她描述了她所看到的。身材矮小、卷发的女性，穿着 1930 年代的风格。后来，在和房主翻看旧照片时，斯蒂芬妮指着一张照片。“费恩·基林斯 [?]”，上面写着。就是她。就是那个女人。原来费恩就是那个死于肺结核的女人，她的尸体在小屋里放了一个月。斯蒂芬妮很困惑为什么她会看到尸体，直到她在树丛后面发现了埋葬费恩的墓地。
I'm hearing the voice of a little girl that continuously says something about playing. Are you coming to play? Or did you come to play?
我听到一个小女孩的声音，一直在说关于玩耍的事情。你要来玩吗？还是你来玩了？
Who blocked the camera?
谁挡住了镜头？
I did, sorry.
是我，抱歉。
I would like to ask who's in spirit to come forward please. And you need to know that you are very safe right now. I got a reference to a guest house, an immediate guest house. I feel like we're not alone right now.
我想请灵体现身。你需要知道你现在很安全。我得到了一个关于客房的提示，一个临时的客房。我觉得我们现在不是一个人。
Patricia's taking photos at the other end of the small cemetery.
帕特里夏在小墓地的另一端拍照。
Well, you kind of get used to being in the dark. Out in the woods, you have to deal with animals and stuff like that too.
嗯，你习惯了待在黑暗中。在森林里，你还得应对动物之类的东西。
I mean, I can handle a chipmunk. But seeing a body? I mean this is so Blair Witch. We are tromping through the woods.
我的意思是，我可以对付花栗鼠。但看到尸体？我的意思是这太像《女巫布莱尔》了。我们在森林里跋涉。
I know it's like oop, uh oh, be careful. Oh, be careful. Oh my God. You're going to kill yourself.
我知道，就像喔，呃，小心，噢，小心，我的天哪，你会杀了你自己的。
I'm not very graceful.
我不太优雅。
It's all right. My father dealt with dealing with MS, and it was a progressive illness that incapacitated him. He died a year ago in May.
没关系。我父亲曾患有多发性硬化症，这是一种进行性疾病，让他丧失了行动能力。他去年五月去世了。
This is Patricia.
这是帕特里夏。
We'd talked a little bit about ghost hunting. He'd ask me questions. He was very open to that. And my mom is too. But I asked him, if he had a chance to come back to please come back and let me know that he was OK. And when he did pass away, I was there. And being a part of this group, even in that short period of time, changed my perspective on death. I used to think about death and be afraid. I don't have that fear anymore. But he's been back since. I was home, and I was up late. And I turned the light on, and it went off a few minutes afterwards. And I said, hi daddy. And it went right back on.
我们谈过一点捉鬼的事。他会问我问题。他对这很开放。我妈妈也是。但我问他，如果他有机会回来，请回来让我知道他很好。当他去世时，我在那里。作为这个团体的一部分，即使在很短的时间内，也改变了我对死亡的看法。我过去常想死亡，并感到害怕。我不再有那种恐惧了。但他回来过。我在家里，睡得很晚。我打开灯，几分钟后它关了。我说，嗨爸爸。然后灯立刻又亮了。
I've been startled awake before. But having a psychic sleeping on the sofa next to me in a haunted cabin bolt up at 3:00 AM crying, there's someone coming, well, that's just scary. People grab whatever gear they fell asleep with. Somehow, I remember to put on my headphones and start stabbing at buttons on my recorder.
我以前也被惊醒过。但在闹鬼的小屋里，身边睡着的灵媒在凌晨 3 点哭着惊醒说“有人来了”，那真是太可怕了。人们抓起他们睡觉时放在身边的任何装备。不知怎么的，我记得戴上耳机，开始猛按记录仪上的按钮。
3:00 AM.
凌晨 3 点。
You know what? Something just moved right there.
你知道吗？刚才有什么东西动了。
Outside?
外面？
No, right here. Right along this way right here. Right where Kendra is, but through that door. Not going that way, but going this way. That was really weird.
不，就在这里。就在这条路上。就在肯德拉所在的位置，但穿过那扇门。不是往那边走，而是往这边走。那真的很奇怪。
We all shuffle around together in a tight bunch. She guides us to the kitchen.
我们都紧紧挤在一起移动。她带我们去厨房。
OK, that was definitely something in the kitchen. Definitely. Does anyone have any recorders going? You have one with you right now? Oh, you're recording this?
好吧，厨房里肯定有什么东西。绝对是。有人开着录音机吗？你现在带着一个吗？噢，你在录这个？
Yeah.
是的。
OK. Get in the middle.
好的。到中间来。
Oh god.
噢，天哪。
Over here, will you? Don't be afraid.
到这边来，好吗？不要害怕。
In their panic, no one had strapped on their tape recorder. They look at me and my big mike. I'm pushed into the dark kitchen. They can see me and my trembling microphone in the night vision camera. But I can't see a thing.
惊慌失措中，没人戴上录音机。他们看着我和我的大麦克风。我被推到黑暗的厨房里。他们在夜视摄像机里能看到我和我颤抖的麦克风。但我什么也看不见。
Is there anyone here with us? We need confirmation please. Would you tell us your name please? Can you give us a physical sign that you're here with us please?
这里有人和我们在一起吗？我们需要确认。你能告诉我们你的名字吗？你能给我们一个你在这里的身体信号吗？
I feel my left side lift, all the hairs standing up. Is this a seizure? Wow, they say. What? I say. There's an orb near your left side. Point the microphone at the floor.
我感到我的左侧升起，所有的毛发都竖起来了。这是癫痫发作吗？哇，他们说。什么？我说。你左侧附近有一个光球。把麦克风指向地板。
A presence over there. I'm hoping that you'll get a female's voice when you replay that. You have to really listen. But I'm hoping that you'll pick something up. Because I sure felt it really strong right in there.
那边有一个存在。我希望回放的时候你能听到一个女性的声音。你必须仔细听。但我希望你能捕捉到什么。因为我确实在那儿感觉非常强烈。
We go into the main room. Stephanie points at the ceiling. Upstairs, video cameras and a computer monitoring system are running. Everyone is leaving, afraid, she says. I point my mike up to the ceiling. Everyone listens closely. Then we hear it, a mouse. I hit pause on my recorder. Kendra's walking towards the front door taking EMF readings. Then Stephanie, in a frightened and direct voice, tells her to, stop, someone's coming. This is when the front door blows open. I hit record.
我们进入主房间。斯蒂芬妮指向天花板。楼上，摄像机和计算机监控系统正在运行。她说大家都在离开，很害怕。我把麦克风指向天花板。每个人都仔细聆听。然后我们听到了，一只老鼠。我按下了录音机的暂停键。肯德拉走向前门读电磁场数值。然后斯蒂芬妮用惊恐而直接的声音叫她，“停下，有人来了”。就在这时，前门被吹开了。我按下了录音键。
Relax.
放松。
Cool.
酷。
Just relax. OK, I just got a big chill. Everybody just wait a minute. Please let me just gather myself. I have a definite male presence right there. And I feel really afraid right now.
放松点。好的，我刚才感觉到一阵恶寒。大家等一下。请让我平复一下。我感觉到那里有一个明确的男性存在。我现在真的感觉很害怕。
Possible orb?
可能是光球？
I have a really, really, really strong male presence here.
我在这里感觉到了一个非常、非常、非常强烈的男性存在。
Gone.
走了。
I don't want anybody to move. Kendra, he just walked right by you. Just don't move. Don't move. Please don't move. Stephanie, don't move. He's still walking by us. Right here. He seems like he's looking for something. Just a minute please. The whole house is unsettled with this presence. I feel like the whole house is staying quiet for a reason. Like nobody move, that's what I feel like. And I totally feel like he's right here. Like right over in here. He doesn't want to talk to me because I'm female or something. I don't know. He doesn't want to talk to me.
我不希望任何人动。肯德拉，他刚才就从你身边走过。别动。别动。请别动。斯蒂芬妮，别动。他还在我们身边走过。就在这儿。他好像在找什么东西。请等一分钟。整个房子因为这个存在而感到不安。我觉得整个房子安静是有原因的。就像“没人动”，我感觉就是这样。而且我完全感觉到他就在这儿。就像就在这附近。他不想和我说话，因为我是女性或者是别的什么。我不知道。他不想和我说话。
By this point, Ross and I have told Stephanie about the history of the cabin. And she thinks, maybe this is the man who was here 70 years ago, the one who people think abused the children at Bible camp, a spirit stuck in a routine.
到此为止，罗斯和我已经告诉了斯蒂芬妮小屋的历史。她想，也许这就是70年前在这里的那个人，那个人们认为在圣经营地虐待孩子的人，一个被困在循环中的灵魂。
He's gone for sure.
他肯定走了。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
Dang, that was harsh. That's terribly sad. He's not ready to deal with it. He's just not ready to deal with it.
该死，太粗暴了。太令人难过了。他还没准备好处理这件事。他只是还没准备好面对。
Shutting the door.
关门。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
In the diffused light of morning, all is well. I'm woken up to giggles. Stephanie is having a really fun time tapping on Steph's sleeping head.
在清晨的漫射光下，一切都好。我在咯咯的笑声中醒来。斯蒂芬妮正在愉快地敲打斯蒂芬正在熟睡的头。
That was so funny.
那太有趣了。
Did you knock me on the head?
是你敲我的头吗？
We've been laughing at you.
我们一直在笑你。
Because then you looked up and thought it was Ross.
因为你抬头看时以为是罗斯。
Kendra, how'd you think it went last night?
肯德拉，你觉得昨晚怎么样？
Kind of odd to hear the noises that I heard. But then again, it could have been my mind playing tricks on me too.
听到那些声音很奇怪。但话说回来，这也可能是我的大脑在跟我开玩笑。
We all stumble upstairs to see what clues the ghosts left us. The scrabble pieces we lined up in the attic had not been moved. They've had luck in the past. Once the pieces were moved to spell cat. The EMF detectors never went off. There were no unexplained voices on my tapes. The strangest thing to happen was that the video recorders and computerized motion and temperature detectors we had running in the empty attic shut off an hour into the two the batteries were supposed to last. And I did see a lot of orbs on the video monitors, plus a couple in my photos.
我们都跌跌撞撞地走上楼去看鬼魂留下了什么线索。我们在阁楼排成的拼字游戏字母没有被动过。他们过去曾有过好运。有一次字母拼出了“猫”。电磁场探测器从没响过。我的磁带上没有无法解释的声音。发生的最奇怪的事情是，我们在空荡荡的阁楼里运行的录像机和计算机化运动及温度探测器在电池本应持续两个小时的情况下，运行了一小时就关掉了。我确实在视频监视器上看到了很多光球，还在照片里拍到了几个。
So do you think this place is haunted?
所以你觉得这里闹鬼吗？
I don't know. But I mean the stuff on the video was pretty weird. Haunted, I don't know. What do you think?
我不知道。但我的意思是视频里的东西真的很奇怪。闹鬼，我不知道。你觉得呢？
It's really hard to say.
真的很难说。
What do you think that whole thing at 3:00 AM was when the door opened?
你觉得凌晨 3 点门打开时是怎么回事？
When it flew open? I don't know.
当它飞开的时候？我不知道。
It felt like the wind to me.
我觉得那是风。
Yeah, I was going to say, it could have been the wind. But before it happened, again, we had a lot of things building up to that.
是的，我也想说，可能是风。但在发生之前，再次强调，我们有很多事情导致了那个结果。
But not like, that's a ghost.
但不是那种“那就是鬼”的感觉。
No. Not enough for me to support that it was a ghost because we did have a lot of wind that night. And that door is really hard to latch.
不。不足以支持那是鬼，因为那天晚上的风确实很大。那扇门真的很难锁上。
The week before this trip, my mom's best friend-- my Auntie Mame as I called her, she even called me Patrick-- died. I was shocked, still am. This is the first time I lost someone close to me and wasn't unable to say a proper goodbye. When each of my parents died, I was with them. I want to believe in ghosts. I want to say goodbye to my Auntie Mame. And I want to believe that my parents and grandparents, who said they'd always be there for me, in fact, are.
这次旅行前一周，我妈妈最好的朋友——我叫她梅阿姨，她甚至叫我帕特里克——去世了。我很震惊，现在依然是。这是我第一次失去亲近的人且没能好好告别。我的父母去世时，我都在他们身边。我想要相信鬼魂。我想要和梅阿姨告别。我想要相信我的父母和祖父母，他们说会一直在我身边，事实上，他们确实在。
I'm going to join Amateur Ghost Hunters of Seattle-Tacoma, pay my $30 and get my badge and T-shirt. So maybe someday, during some investigation with AGHOST, chasing around a haunted place, or after midnight in some cemetery, I'll see or hear something that will make me believe that there is life after death, that ghosts do exist.
我要加入西雅图-塔科马业余捉鬼人协会，交 30 美元，领我的徽章和 T 恤。所以也许有一天，在 AGHOST 的某个调查中，追逐某个闹鬼的地方，或者在午夜的某个墓地，我会看到或听到让我相信死后有生命、鬼魂确实存在的东西。
Are we all here?
我们都到了吗？
Yup.
到了。
We need to thank all spirit for allowing us to have the experience that we did last night. We want to make sure that you stay here. This is where you need to be right now. We'll be back.
我们要感谢所有的灵体让我们有了昨晚的经历。我们要确保你待在这里。这是你现在需要待的地方。我们会回来的。
Jake Warga. His story got some support from hearingvoices.com and the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
杰克·瓦加。他的故事得到了一些来自 hearingvoices.com 和公共广播公司的支持。
[MUSIC - "FADED FROM THE WINTER" BY IRON & WINE]
[音乐 - “FADED FROM THE WINTER” - IRON & WINE]
Act Two, Government Science. A couple months ago, the Union of Concerned Scientists issued a report condemning the Bush administration for what it called "distorting and censoring" scientific findings which contradict administration policies. One of the cases cited in the report involved something called the Advisory Committee on Childhood Lead Poisoning. This committee is one of about two dozen in the Centers for Disease Control. Its mission is to advise the CDC how best to deal with the threat of childhood lead poisoning. The advisory committee has existed, in one form or another, for 30 years, starting in the '70s when the battle was to get the lead out of gasoline. Alex Blumberg has been following the recent fights over who's going to serve in this committee. Each side in the fight thinks the other is practicing a kind of fake science. Here's Alex.
第二幕，政府科学。几个月前，忧思科学家联盟发布了一份报告，谴责布什政府“扭曲和审查”与行政政策相矛盾的科学发现。报告中提到的案例之一涉及一个叫“儿童铅中毒咨询委员会”的组织。该委员会是疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）下属的二十几个委员会之一。其使命是建议 CDC 如何最好地应对儿童铅中毒的威胁。该咨询委员会以各种形式存在了 30 年，始于 70 年代，当时战斗的目标是清除汽油中的铅。亚历克斯·布隆伯格一直在追踪关于谁将进入该委员会的近期斗争。争论的每一方都认为对方是在进行一种伪科学。以下是亚历克斯的报道。
Dr. Bruce Lanphear is exactly the type of person you'd expect to find on something called an Advisory Committee for Childhood Lead Poisoning Prevention. He's been the lead researcher on numerous studies investigating the effects of lead on children. He's a scientific consultant to the National Center for Lead-Safe Housing. And he's the author of a whole stack of scientific articles with titles like, "The effect of soil abatement on blood lead levels in children living near a former smelting and milling operation." So it's no surprise that the CDC got in touch with him.
布鲁斯·兰菲尔博士正是你期望在名为“儿童铅中毒预防咨询委员会”的机构中找到的那类人。他是众多调查铅对儿童影响的研究的主要研究员。他是国家铅安全住房中心的科学顾问，也是一大堆科学文章的作者，标题诸如“土壤治理对居住在旧冶炼和铣削操作附近的儿童血铅水平的影响”。所以 CDC 联系他并不奇怪。
Sitting in my office in a research building, now about the three years ago, I received a call from a CDC official who asked whether I'd be willing to be nominated to be a member of the CDC Lead Advisory Committee. And my name along with, I think, three other people at that time was submitted to the Secretary of Health.
现在大约三年前，坐在研究大楼的办公室里，我接到了 CDC 一位官员的电话，问我是否愿意被提名为 CDC 铅咨询委员会的成员。我的名字连同当时我认为的其他三个人一起提交给了卫生部长。
Serving on a CDC scientific advisory committee is the elite, scientific version of serving on a task force at your local school board. Committee members aren't paid a salary. They keep their old jobs. They're just private citizens who meet a couple of times a year and offer their expertise and energy to help solve problems. They have no regulatory authority. They don't even set policy. But because they are some of the leading experts in the field, their recommendations carry weight. The CDC told Dr. Lanphear that he should expect to begin work on the committee in a couple months, after the largely pro forma approval of his nomination was complete. But this was an election year. The Bush administration took power. And it took roughly a year and a half after he was first contacted for Dr. Lanphear to get another call from a CDC official.
在 CDC 科学咨询委员会任职，是科学界的精英版，相当于在当地教育委员会的特别工作组任职。委员会成员没有工资。他们保留原来的工作。他们只是普通公民，每年开几次会，贡献他们的专业知识和精力来帮助解决问题。他们没有监管权力。他们甚至不制定政策。但因为他们是该领域的一些顶尖专家，他们的建议具有分量。CDC 告诉兰菲尔博士，预计他在提名获得大致礼节性的批准后，几个月内就开始委员会的工作。但这正值大选年。布什政府上台了。兰菲尔博士在第一次接到联系后，大约一年半才再次接到 CDC 官员的电话。
Saying that he was a bit concerned that the representatives of the lead industry had put forward their own nominations and argued against the three people who had been nominated by the CDC officials. About a month later, the appointment was denied for me and, again, my two colleagues who had expertise in lead poisoning prevention. And the nominees who had been put forward by the lead industry were approved in place.
说他有点担心，因为铅行业的代表提出了他们自己的提名，并反对由 CDC 官员提名的那三个人。大约一个月后，我和我的两位同样在铅中毒预防方面有专业知识的同事的任命被拒绝了。而铅行业提名的候选人被批准填补了位置。
There was some nonsense that I was somehow a Republican or something. That's craziness. And as a matter of fact, I voted for Bill Clinton.
有些无稽之谈说我是某种共和党人还是什么。那是疯话。事实上，我投了比尔·克林顿的票。
Dr. William Banner is the man who was appointed to the committee instead of Dr. Lanphear. And if you've ever wondered about that scientist industry trots out to say, all this research is wrong, smoking doesn't cause cancer, the climate is not changing, and lead paint isn't dangerous for kids, here he is. A liberal pediatrician in Oklahoma. Dr. Banner runs a children's hospital and is the medical director for the Oklahoma Poison Control Center. He doesn't want to loosen the current CDC recommendations about how much lead in kids' blood is safe. From my hour-long conversation with him, he seems to care deeply about the welfare of children in this state. He's an ardent supporter of Head Start. And he told me that the greatest threat to children that he saw was a recent change in the welfare law which kicks families off of government assistance. But he has also, on many occasions, been an expert witness for the lead industry, that is, companies like paint manufacturers who are being sued over the lead content in their products. They hire him because he's willing to say on the witness stand that none of the studies connecting lead and children's cognitive development are conclusive.
威廉·班纳博士是被任命进入委员会而不是兰菲尔博士的人。如果你曾经好奇过那个被行业推出来说“所有这些研究都是错的，吸烟不致癌，气候没有变化，铅漆对孩子不危险”的科学家是谁，那就是他。俄克拉荷马州的一位自由派儿科医生。班纳博士经营着一家儿童医院，也是俄克拉荷马毒物控制中心的医学主任。他不想放宽 CDC 目前关于儿童血液中多少含铅量是安全的建议。在我与他进行的一小时交谈中，他似乎非常关心该州儿童的福利。他是“启智计划”的坚定支持者。他告诉我，他所见到的对儿童最大的威胁是最近福利法的修改，这使得家庭失去了政府援助。但他也多次担任铅行业的专家证人，也就是说，那些因产品含铅而被起诉的油漆制造商等公司。他们雇佣他是因为他愿意在证人席上说，所有联系铅和儿童认知发展的研究都不是决定性的。
Who called you to be a member of this committee?
谁叫你担任这个委员会成员的？
Well, I don't remember who it was. It was somebody that is involved in public relations, I think, for probably one of the national lead-- probably somebody from one of the companies. And I didn't hear anything more about. And I forgot about it. And then, the first thing I knew was that I got a letter from Health and Human Services asking me if I wished to submit a nominating letter.
嗯，我不记得是谁了。我想大概是国家铅行业的某个人，可能来自某家公司的人。之后我就没再听到什么了。我把它忘了。然后，我首先知道的是，我收到了一封卫生与公众服务部的信，问我是否希望提交提名信。
Dr. Banner went to his boss, the director of the hospital where he works, said, hey, the government wants someone to nominate me for this committee. And his boss said, sure, we'll send a letter. And so now, when you call the government, as I did, and ask about Bill Banner, he sounds great.
班纳博士去找了他的老板，他工作的那家医院的院长，说，嘿，政府想让人提名我参加这个委员会。他的老板说，当然，我们会发一封信。所以现在，当你像我一样致电政府询问比尔·班纳时，他听起来很棒。
Medical Director of the Children's Hospital at Saint Francis in Tulsa, the Oklahoma Poison Control Center Medical Director. And he was recommended to us by the head of the hospital.
塔尔萨圣弗朗西斯儿童医院的医学主任，俄克拉荷马毒物控制中心的医学主任。他是医院负责人推荐给我们的。
This is Bill Pierce, the media relations guy for Tommy Thompson, the man appointed by George Bush to run the Department of Health and Human Services, HHS, which runs the CDC. Bill Pierce assured me that, contrary to what everybody I talked to told me, it was very common to overrule specific CDC nominations and appoint different people.
这是比尔·皮尔斯，汤米·汤普森的媒体公关人员，汤米·汤普森是由乔治·布什任命管理卫生与公众服务部（HHS）的人，该部门管理着 CDC。比尔·皮尔斯向我保证，与我交谈过的所有人所说的相反，否决特定的 CDC 提名并任命不同的人是非常普遍的。
Let me ask one other question about Dr. Banner. He has testified several times on behalf of the lead industry. And at the time that he was appointed, you had Dr. Weitzman and Dr. Lanphear, both of whom have just pages and pages of publications to their name, dealing with the very issue of lead poisoning. And then you have a person put on the committee who hasn't really published anything about lead poisoning and whose name was given to HHS by representatives of the lead industry.
关于班纳博士，我再问一个问题。他曾多次代表铅行业作证。在他被任命时，你有威茨曼博士和兰菲尔博士，他们名下都有页数众多的出版物，处理的正是铅中毒的问题。然后你有一个在委员会任职的人，他并没有真正发表过关于铅中毒的文章，他的名字是由铅行业代表交给 HHS 的。
That's the claim made. That's not true. Again, he was recommended by Robert Scott, executive vice president of Saint Francis Hospital, the hospital that he works in. Again, this is stuff made up by people.
那是提出的说法。那是不真实的。再说一次，他是被他工作的医院，圣弗朗西斯医院的执行副院长罗伯特·斯科特推荐的。再说一次，这是人们编造的东西。
But this is from when I talked to him. He said that the people who first asked him if he wanted to be nominated were representatives of the lead industry.
但这来自我与他的谈话。他说最初问他是否想被提名的人是铅行业的代表。
Hey, again, it's a free country. Anybody can talk to him and ask him whatever they want. I could ask you, for instance, all kinds of questions. Does it mean anything?
嘿，再说一次，这是一个自由的国家。任何人都可以和他交谈，问他任何他们想问的事。例如，我可以问你各种各样的问题。这意味着什么吗？
I guess--
我想——
It truly doesn't mean anything. We were not contacted by anybody in any industry regarding Dr. Banner.
确实什么都不意味着。没有行业内的任何人就班纳博士与我们联系过。
So you're saying it's a coincidence that somebody called him up from the lead industry and said, we want to nominate you for this, and then he got nominated?
所以你是说，有人从铅行业给他打电话说“我们想提名你”，然后他被提名，这只是一个巧合？
I have no idea. I don't know anything about that. We don't know anything about that conversation. Alex, again, I just-- you and I could probably talk and find out six connections we have. Doesn't mean anything. We've never talked except for this week. Doesn't mean anything.
我不知道。我对此一无所知。我们对那个对话一无所知。亚历克斯，再说一次，我只是——你和我可能谈论并找出我们有的六个联系。什么都不意味着。我们从来没谈过，除了这周。什么都不意味着。
Right. I guess it just seems-- can you understand, though, how that might seem suspicious?
对。我想——你能理解这看起来可能很可疑吗？
No.
不能。
You can't?
你不能？
No. Again, I deal in facts. I deal in reality. I don't deal in conspiracy theories. So it doesn't matter what anybody else said to Dr. Banner on their own. He is well qualified to serve on this committee.
不能。再说一次，我处理事实。我处理现实。我不处理阴谋论。所以别人私下对班纳博士说了什么并不重要。他完全有资格在这个委员会任职。
The question of whether Dr. Banner is qualified to serve on this committee is an interesting one. On the one hand, he has some very sensible opinions about government policies on lead. For instance, he didn't agree with the federal recommendations in the early '90s that said every child in the country should be tested for lead. In his rural state of Oklahoma, far away from old, deteriorating housing stock and big industrial smelters, lead wasn't the problem for children, he thought. Poor nutrition and a low immunization rate were. He didn't like having to spend what little money he had on a problem that, in his view, didn't exist.
关于班纳博士是否有资格在委员会任职的问题是一个有趣的问题。一方面，他在政府铅政策上有一些非常合理的意见。例如，他不同意 90 年代初联邦建议全国每个孩子都应进行铅检测。在他所在的农村州俄克拉荷马州，远离旧的、破旧的住房和大型工业冶炼厂，他认为铅对儿童来说不是问题。营养不良和免疫接种率低才是。他不喜欢花原本就有限的钱去解决一个他认为不存在的问题。
On the other hand, he hasn't done any research on the effects of lead exposure on children. And his opinions of other people's research run counter to what pretty much every scientist in the field would say.
另一方面，他没有做过任何关于铅暴露对儿童影响的研究。他对其他人研究的观点与该领域几乎所有科学家的说法背道而驰。
Do I believe the studies, these epidemiological studies that have attempted to correlate IQ with the lead levels? No.
我是否相信这些试图关联智商和铅水平的流行病学研究？不。
What he's talking about is this. Over the last 10 or 20 years, many researchers working in many different countries with many different populations, have done studies investigating the link between elevated amounts of lead in children's blood and loss of IQ. They take a sample of children, measure their lead levels, give them an intelligence test, use a bunch of fancy statistical techniques to control for other factors, like parents' IQ. And in every study, they show a link between higher blood lead levels and lower IQ. But Dr. Banner says, they prove nothing. They can't, he says, by their very nature. They're statistical studies. Even when they show a correlation between lead and IQ loss, it could be coincidental. They tell us nothing about cells in the brain and what lead does to those cells.
他说的是这个。在过去 10 或 20 年里，许多在不同国家、不同人群中工作的研究人员进行了研究，调查儿童血液中高浓度铅与智商损失之间的联系。他们选取儿童样本，测量他们的铅水平，给他们做智力测试，使用一系列精巧的统计技术来控制其他因素，比如父母的智商。在每一项研究中，他们都显示了较高的血铅水平与较低智商之间的联系。但班纳博士说，这些证明不了什么。他说，从本质上讲，它们不能。它们是统计研究。即使它们显示铅与智商损失之间的相关性，也可能是巧合。它们没有告诉我们关于大脑细胞的任何信息，以及铅对这些细胞做了什么。
I think they fall far short of science. And I take issue with the way they have done. And frankly, I think they have reached the conclusions that they wished to conclude and ignored the alternative hypotheses. And it has become very politicized. Epidemiology itself is an infant as a science. And I think the rules are ill-formed at this point.
我认为它们离科学还差得很远。我对他采取的方式有异议。坦率地说，我认为他们得出了他们希望得出的结论，而忽略了替代假设。它已经变得非常政治化了。流行病学本身作为一门科学还处于起步阶段。我认为目前的规则还不完善。
Dr. Banner presents a compelling portrait of himself, a maverick scientist with common sense bravely telling the emperor, in this case multiple regression analysis, that it has no clothes. But to most experts in public health, to deny this research is basically denying the mathematical basis of all modern epidemiology which studies the spread of disease by applying the same techniques in the blood lead studies to hundreds of other health areas. Dr. Michael Weitzman has worked for 30 years doing field epidemiological research on children's health issues. For him, it's like denying that the earth is round.
班纳博士展示了一幅引人注目的自画像，一位有常识的特立独行的科学家，勇敢地告诉皇帝——在这种情况下是多元回归分析——他没有穿衣服。但对于大多数公共卫生专家来说，否认这项研究基本上是否认所有现代流行病学的数学基础，流行病学通过将血铅研究中的相同技术应用于数百个其他健康领域来研究疾病的传播。迈克尔·威茨曼博士从事儿童健康问题的实地流行病学研究已经 30 年了。对他来说，这就像否认地球是圆的一样。
Is it possible that there are limitations to epidemiology? You bet. It's very difficult to develop a causal argument when we show associations between things. But when you have dozens, if not hundreds, of studies in different countries using different methods with different techniques showing the same thing, then how can you say that you question it?
流行病学是否存在局限性？那是肯定的。当我们显示事物之间的关联时，提出因果论证是非常困难的。但是当你拥有不同国家、使用不同方法、不同技术、显示相同结果的几十甚至几百项研究时，你又怎么能说你对此质疑呢？
Especially, he says, when epidemiology gets results. Using only mathematics, epidemiologists have eradicated a number of diseases without any understanding of the basic biology. For instance, Reye's Syndrome, which killed a lot of school-aged children in the 1970s.
他说，尤其是当流行病学取得结果时。仅使用数学，流行病学家在没有任何基础生物学理解的情况下就根除了许多疾病。例如，瑞氏综合征，在 20 世纪 70 年代杀死了许多学龄儿童。
And epidemiologic approaches found that the thing that these kids had in common is that virtually all these kids either have had chicken pox or the flu at the same time that they had taken aspirin. And so that led to the federal government making all sorts of recommendations that children under the age of 12 not take aspirin. And you know what? The disease has gone away. It's completely disappeared.
流行病学方法发现，这些孩子共同点在于，几乎所有这些孩子在服用阿司匹林的同时都患有水痘或流感。因此，这导致联邦政府提出了各种建议，要求 12 岁以下的孩子不要服用阿司匹林。你知道吗？这种病已经消失了。它完全消失了。
Bill Pierce, the spokesman for HHS, didn't want to talk to me about any of this initially. He was convinced that I, like every other reporter, had an agenda. I'd been spun by the Union of Concerned Scientists and by a webpage put up by Representative Henry Waxman, which attacks Bush administration policies regarding science. He said that these things all made mountains out of molehills and ignored something much more fundamental.
比尔·皮尔斯，HHS 的发言人，最初并不想和我谈论这些。他坚信像其他记者一样，我有预谋。我被忧思科学家联盟以及亨利·瓦克斯曼议员建立的一个网页所操纵，该网页攻击布什政府关于科学的政策。他说这些事情都是小题大做，忽略了一些更根本的东西。
All the claims made by the naysayers out there, the conspiratorial theorists-- if these people are appointed, somehow bad things are going to happen-- haven't come true. These committees are serving. These people are on these committees. These committees are meeting. Advice is being provided. So I ask them, where's the beef, as the old cliche is in the old commercial. Where's the beef? There is no beef. I ask and challenge the media. I ask and challenge all of you. Do that. Take a look. What's the point here? What is the point of these arguments that are being made?
外面所有那些反对者、阴谋论者提出的说法——如果这些人被任命，某种坏事就会发生——并没有成为现实。这些委员会正在运作。这些人就在这些委员会中。这些委员会正在开会。正在提供建议。所以我问他们，老商业广告中的陈词滥调，“牛肉在哪里？” 牛肉在哪里？根本没有牛肉。我请求并挑战媒体。我请求并挑战你们所有人。去做吧。看一看。这里的重点是什么？这些争论的重点是什么？
He's right. Even experts who got rejected from the committee agree that they probably wouldn't have done much different from the current committee members. But there is something at stake. And that is, how do we view science? Bill Pierce said to me, listen, there's Democratic scientific experts, and there's Republican scientific experts. Democrats appoint the Democratic experts. And when Republicans come in, they appoint the Republican experts, Dr. Banner notwithstanding. But this is actually a fundamental shift. Consider J. Routt Reigart, a professor of pediatrics in South Carolina. He drafted the very first document the CDC ever issued about lead poisoning back in the 1970s. He's been involved with the CDC on one committee or another ever since, from Nixon to Clinton. And he says, in the past, appointments were not political.
他是对的。即使是被委员会拒绝的专家也承认，他们可能不会比目前的委员会成员做得更好。但有一些东西正处于危险之中。那就是，我们如何看待科学？比尔·皮尔斯对我说，听着，有民主党的科学专家，也有共和党的科学专家。民主党任命民主党的专家。共和党进来时，他们任命共和党的专家，尽管有班纳博士。但这实际上是一个根本性的转变。考虑一下南卡罗来纳州的儿科教授 J.劳特·里加特。他在 20 世纪 70 年代起草了 CDC 发布的第一份关于铅中毒的文件。从尼克松到克林顿，他一直参与 CDC 的各种委员会。他说，在过去，任命不是政治性的。
That part was definitely a change in that nominations were going up from CDC and were being not only rejected by the secretary, but the secretary telling the center who should be on the committee, which was quite a different event than I was familiar with in the past.
那部分确实是一个变化，提名从 CDC 上报，不仅被部长拒绝，而且部长告诉中心谁应该在委员会中，这与我过去熟悉的情况有很大的不同。
And this is going back--
这是追溯到——
Oh that's going back as far as I can remember.
噢，这可以追溯到我记忆所及的最早。
That's back to the '70s?
那是回到 70 年代？
Yeah.
是的。
The Bush administration suggests that science is just like politics. Dr. Banner has his opinion, Dr. Lanphear has his, and they're both valid. But that's not actually how science works. Science is based on the premise that there are not two equally valid points of view on all issues, that there's a verifiable truth to things. That one side is right, and one side is wrong. And science has a process in place to figure that out. And so, Dr. Reigart says, there is an objective difference between Dr. Banner and Dr. Lanphear.
布什政府暗示科学就像政治一样。班纳博士有他的观点，兰菲尔博士有他的，它们都是有效的。但这不是科学的工作方式。科学基于这样一个前提，即在所有问题上不存在两种同样有效的观点，即事物有可验证的真理。一边是对的，一边是错的。科学有一个程序来找出这一点。因此，里加特博士说，班纳博士和兰菲尔博士之间存在客观差异。
Dr. Lanphear, every time he submits a proposal, he has to justify everything he wants to do, why he wants to do, what his preliminary data is. So he can't get the money unless he has a scientifically defensible point of view. Whereas Dr. Banner's statements about lead poisoning-- if he has research that refutes those studies, then he should publish it. And then we have something to talk about.
兰菲尔博士，他每次提交提案，他都必须为他想做的每一件事辩护，为什么他想做，他的初步数据是什么。所以除非他有科学上站得住脚的观点，否则他拿不到钱。而班纳博士关于铅中毒的陈述——如果他有反驳这些研究的研究，那么他应该发表它。然后我们就有东西可谈了。
In other words, Dr. Banner can raise his concerns about experimental methodology in courtrooms all over the country and to reporters on the radio and at public advisory meetings for the CDC. But science has already settled those questions long ago. Of the 12 members in the current Lead Advisory Committee, only one could be considered a leading researcher on the effects of lead on children. And he's rotating off at the end of the month. It'll be a science advisory committee without any scientific expertise. In the case of lead, this might not be so dangerous. The science concerning lead has been settled, more or less, for years. But on dozens of other committees appointed this way, committees which investigate global climate change, for example, or the effects of pesticides on human health, committees where the issues are much less clear, we need every expert we can find.
换句话说，班纳博士可以在全国各地的法庭上，在广播电台的记者面前，以及在 CDC 的公共咨询会议上提出他对实验方法论的担忧。但科学早在很久以前就解决了这些问题。在目前的铅咨询委员会的 12 名成员中，只有一人可以被认为是关于铅对儿童影响的顶尖研究人员。而且他将在本月底轮换离任。这将是一个没有任何科学专业知识的科学咨询委员会。在铅的情况下，这可能没那么危险。关于铅的科学，或多或少已经确定多年了。但是，在以这种方式任命的其他几十个委员会中，例如调查全球气候变化的委员会，或杀虫剂对人类健康影响的委员会，在这些问题不那么清楚的委员会中，我们需要我们能找到的每一位专家。
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our show. Coming up. I hear dead people, part two, more real recordings. And how to determine whether you, yes you, are objectively as beautiful as the stars. Facts, details, analyses. That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来。我听到了死人说话，第二部分，更多真实录音。以及如何确定你，是的你，是否和星星一样客观地美丽。事实、细节、分析。这些将在芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的一分钟节目后，当我们的节目继续时播出。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme. We bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Fake Science, stories of people employing scientific logic, scientific analyses wrongly. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Beauty Science. There's a whole-- I don't even know the word-- there's a whole tendency in certain people to try to apply objective standards, find objective standards, pseudo-scientific standards, to things that, frankly, are never going to be objective. You know what I'm talking about? You've seen those scholars who write books explaining why comedy is funny. That's what I'm talking about. Some things are really better off left unexamined, far from the groping, sweating, parsing, greedy hands of fake scientists of all kinds. And for an example of this, all you need to do is look at this article that's on the website Fametracker.com. It points out a recent attempt by a famous magazine, one that is on newsstands right now, to dive into this area. Adam Sternbergh is the co-founder and co-editor of Fametracker, and he has the story here.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题。我们为你带来关于该主题的各种不同的故事。今天的节目，“伪科学”，人们错误地使用科学逻辑、科学分析的故事。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，“美学科学”。有一种整体——我甚至不知道这个词——某些人有一种整体倾向，试图应用客观标准，寻找客观标准，伪科学标准，去对待那些，坦率地说，永远不会客观的事物。你知道我在说什么吗？你见过那些写书解释为什么喜剧好笑的学者吗？这就是我在说的。有些事情最好不要去检查，远离各种伪科学者的摸索、出汗、解析、贪婪的手。举个例子，你只需要看 Fametracker.com 网站上的这篇文章。它指出了目前在报摊上的一本著名杂志最近试图深入这个领域。亚当·斯特恩伯格是 Fametracker 的联合创始人和联合编辑，他在这里有这个故事。
Yes. It's that time of year. People magazine has once again graciously taken on the task of whittling down the hundreds of blindingly brilliant, gaspingly gorgeous, eye-searingly spectacular celebrities to a final, chart-topping 50. How do they do this? Can you imagine the arguments? Benjamin Bratt. Rodrigo Santoro. Benjamin Bratt. Rodrigo Santoro. Benjamin Bratt. Rodrigo Santoro. Then some poor, unfortunate associate editor gets a letter opener to the eye. And Rodrigo Santoro, the quote Brazilian actor and health-buff, gets page 142.
是的。又是一年中的这个时候。人物杂志再次慷慨地承担了将数百名令人眼花缭乱、光彩夺目、令人瞩目的名人削减到最终入选前 50 名的任务。他们是怎么做的？你能想象争论吗？本杰明·布拉特。罗德里戈·桑托罗。本杰明·布拉特。罗德里戈·桑托罗。本杰明·布拉特。罗德里戈·桑托罗。然后一些倒霉的副编辑用拆信刀刺向眼睛。而那位引用巴西演员和健康达人的罗德里戈·桑托罗上了第 142 页。
This annual culling of the perfect may seem an arduous and arbitrary task. This year, though, People's given us a peek into the process. These selections aren't just the ephemeral whims of overworked editors, their eyes blearied by beauty. No, these selections are made based on the rigorous rules of science. Science, damn it, science. It's about 2/3 the width of his mouth and a perfect 1/3 of the length of his face, and his wide cheekbones and square jaw balance the width. No, this isn't Keats writing another ode, this is Dr. Steven Pearlman, a Manhattan-based plastic surgeon quoted in People . And he's lovingly describing Orlando Bloom's nose. Oh yes, let us see that perfect 1/3 baby.
这种年度对完美的筛选似乎是一项艰巨而武断的任务。不过今年，《人物》杂志让我们窥视了这个过程。这些选择不仅仅是过度劳累的编辑们的短暂心血来潮，他们的眼睛被美景弄花了。不，这些选择是基于科学的严谨规则做出的。科学，该死的，科学。它是他嘴巴宽度的 2/3，脸部长度的完美 1/3，他宽阔的颧骨和方下巴平衡了宽度。不，这不是济慈在写另一首颂歌，这是史蒂文·皮尔曼医生，一位曼哈顿的整形外科医生在《人物》杂志中引用的。他正充满爱意地描述奥兰多·布鲁姆的鼻子。噢是的，让我们看看那个完美的 1/3 宝贝。
Bloom's nose is featured in a section titled, "Most Wanted," which details the most wanted lips, eyes, nose, or cheekbones of the stars. The possessor of each perfect feature is described with a snappy, verb-centric sentence. For example, of Nicole Kidman's skin it says, "She glows." Of Johnny Depp's cheekbones, "He smolders." Of Bloom's coveted nose, "He commands." That's right. Orlando Bloom's nose commands. To do what? It's not entirely clear. It turns out, beauty is not, in fact, in the eye of the beholder, as some olden days person wanted us to believe, whoever that was. Caesar or Jesus. Beauty can be reduced to a mathematical formula. And it's fun to try at home.
布鲁姆的鼻子出现在标题为“最想要的”栏目中，详细介绍了明星们最想要的嘴唇、眼睛、鼻子或颧骨。每个完美特征的拥有者都用一个短小、以动词为中心的句子来描述。例如，关于妮可·基德曼的皮肤，它说，“她闪耀”。关于约翰尼·德普的颧骨，“他闷烧”。关于布鲁姆令人垂涎的鼻子，“他指挥”。没错。奥兰多·布鲁姆的鼻子指挥。指挥什么？不完全清楚。事实证明，美实际上并不在观看者的眼中，正如一些古代人希望我们相信的那样，不管那是谁。恺撒还是耶稣。美可以简化为一个数学公式。而且在家尝试很有趣。
Let's turn to Dr. Francis Palmer, founder of the Beverly Hills International Center for Aesthetic Surgery and co-director of Facial Plastic Surgery at University of Southern California School of Medicine. And with each paragraph-hogging list of professional credentials, you can picture that poor People fact-checker, phone stuck to her ear as the aesthetic surgery doctor in question reads his resume very slowly over the phone, as though speaking to someone who is developmentally delayed, "Beverly Hills Internat-- yes. Aesthetic. OK. A-E-S--"
让我们转向弗朗西斯·帕尔默医生，比佛利山庄国际美学手术中心创始人，南加州大学医学院面部整形手术联合主任。随着每一段占据篇幅的专业资格列表，你可以想象那个可怜的《人物》杂志事实核查员，手机粘在耳朵上，而相关的美学外科医生非常缓慢地在电话里朗读他的简历，就像在对一个发育迟缓的人说话，“比佛利山庄国际——是的。美学。OK。A-E-S——”
Dr. Palmer has quote devised the following point system to determine true beauty. You get 75% of the points for your cheekbones, 10% for eyes and eyebrows, 7% for lips, and 2% each for jaw, chin, and neck, sleek nose, clear skin, and quote general harmony of features. So who scores the highest among, say, recent reality TV babes? Why, it's Survivor's newly minted millionaire, Amber Brkich, with 97%.
帕尔默医生制定了以下积分系统来确定真正的美。你的颧骨占 75% 的分数，眼睛和眉毛占 10%，嘴唇占 7%，下巴、颌和脖子各占 2%，光滑的鼻子、清晰的皮肤，以及“特征的整体和谐”占 2%。那么在最近的真人秀美女中，谁得分最高？为什么，是《幸存者》新晋百万富翁，安布尔·布尔奇，得分 97%。
But where do we, the regular folk, fit in? It's easy to find out. Here's the formula, as printed in People magazine. To do a self-analysis, draw an imaginary line from the pupil of your eye down toward your jaw. Draw a second line from the nostrils across your cheeks. The bottom of your cheek bone should fall at or below the intersection of these lines. If it is higher, your face may appear flat and masculine. So she glows. She sparkles. He smolders. You suck. Hey, that's not our opinion. That's science talking.
但我们这些普通人该放在哪里呢？很容易找到。这里是《人物》杂志上印出的公式。要做自我分析，画一条从眼睛瞳孔向下到下颌的虚线。画第二条从鼻孔穿过脸颊的线。颧骨底部应该落在这些线的交点处或以下。如果它更高，你的脸可能显得平坦而男性化。所以她闪耀。她闪闪发光。他闷烧。你太烂了。嘿，那不是我们的观点。那是科学在说话。
Adam Sternbergh. Read his analyses of both the famous and the very famous at Fametracker.com, where this story first appeared.
亚当·斯特恩伯格。在 Fametracker.com 阅读他对比名人和大名人进行的分析，这个故事最初出现在那里。
[MUSIC - "I AM THE BODY BEAUTIFUL" BY SALT 'N PEPA]
[音乐 - “I AM THE BODY BEAUTIFUL” - SALT 'N PEPA]
Act Four, Radio Science. Fake science can be fun, and it can bring people together. Brent Runyon has heard it happen himself in the middle of the night.
第四幕，广播科学。伪科学可能很有趣，它可以把人们聚在一起。布伦特·鲁尼恩在深夜自己亲耳听到了这种情况。
Most nights I have a hard time going to sleep. I worry a lot when I go to bed. I worry about money and if I should go and work at the movie theater again. I worry that we're not going to be able to stay in this house. And I worry that if we do move, everyone will be miserable. After that, I worry that the Red Sox will never win a World Series, and that Nomar's Achilles is going to require surgery, and that the Yankees will always win no matter what the Red Sox do. I know a lot of people who have trouble going to sleep. Walker, who is 12, needs to have the dishwasher on to go to sleep and the dryer. Grandpa Jim used to count upwards through the prime numbers. I remember when I was a little kid, I used to lie in bed and listen to my parents talking through the wall. Their voices sounded muffled, and I couldn't make out the words. But I liked listening to the sounds.
大多数晚上我很难入睡。我上床时担心很多。我担心钱，担心我是否应该再去电影院工作。我担心我们无法留在这所房子里。而且我担心如果我们搬家，每个人都会很痛苦。之后，我担心红袜队永远不会赢得世界大赛，诺马尔的跟腱需要手术，无论红袜队做什么，洋基队都会一直赢。我认识很多失眠的人。12 岁的沃克需要开着洗碗机和烘干机才能入睡。吉姆爷爷以前喜欢从质数开始往上数。我记得小时候，我常躺在床上听父母透过墙说话。他们的声音很闷，我听不清词语。但我喜欢听那些声音。
Now at night, I turn on the radio, so I can hear voices when I'm going to sleep. It's tuned to the same station the Red Sox games are on, an all-talk station. They have some local guys in the morning and Rush Limbaugh in the afternoon. But at night, they have this program called Coast to Coast AM . I remember the first time I heard the show. It was 1:00 in the morning, and I couldn't sleep. So I turned on the radio. And there were people talking about recordings from beyond the grave. And then they played the recordings. And at first, there was just a lot of tape hiss and a kind of angry grumbling. I was laughing at how silly it was. And then a voice seemed to say, I found the link. Except that instead of saying it in a normal voice, the voice said it in a creepy, David Lynch, Twin Peaks , little man in the red room backward, kind of voice. I sat up in bed and turned the light on. It freaked me out. I was freaked out by some weird voice on a radio show in the middle of the night. And still, I would rather listen to that than worry about money. So I turned the light out and closed my eyes and listened until I fell asleep.
现在到了晚上，我打开收音机，这样我睡觉时就能听到声音。它调到了和红袜队比赛相同的电台，一个全谈话电台。他们早上有一些本地人，下午有拉什·林博。但到了晚上，他们有一个叫《Coast to Coast AM》的节目。我记得第一次听这个节目。凌晨 1 点，我睡不着。所以我打开了收音机。有人在谈论来自坟墓之外的录音。然后他们播放了录音。起初，只有很多磁带嘶嘶声和一种愤怒的咕哝声。我在笑它有多傻。然后一个声音似乎在说，我找到了链接。除了它不是用正常的声音说出来的，那个声音是用一种阴森的、大卫·林奇的《双峰》中红色房间里小矮人倒着说的声音说出来的。我从床上坐起来，打开灯。它吓坏我了。我被深夜广播节目中一些奇怪的声音吓坏了。尽管如此，我宁愿听那个也不愿担心钱。所以我关了灯，闭上眼睛，听着直到入睡。
Since then, I've barely missed a night. It's hard for me to fall asleep without it. I travel with an AM radio. I wait to go to bed until 1:00 AM when the opening music kicks in. And when it does, I don't want to go to sleep anymore.
从那以后，我几乎没有错过一个晚上。没有它我很难入睡。我带着收音机旅行。我等到凌晨 1 点开场音乐响起时才去睡觉。当它响起时，我不想再睡觉了。
From the High Desert and the great American Southwest, I bid you all good evening, good afternoon, good morning, whatever the case may be in whatever time zone you're in.
来自高沙漠和伟大的美国西南部，我祝大家晚上好，下午好，早上好，无论你在什么时区，情况如何。
That's Art Bell, the weekend host of Coast to Coast . He's a ham radio operator in his spare time. He's got a bad back, and he does the show out of his house. The whole program runs like an amateur scientific society from the dawn of the Enlightenment. There's a sense that there's this stuff out there that's barely been studied, and we don't even have good procedures for studying it yet. But if we all sit down and reason together, we can probably make some sense out of it. Aliens, Mars, time travel. Listeners call up to talk about shadow people and this ghoulish figure called the old hag who sits on their chest while they sleep.
那是阿特·贝尔，周末主持《Coast to Coast》。他业余时间是个业余无线电操作员。他背部不好，他在家里主持节目。整个节目像是一个启蒙时代的业余科学协会。有一种感觉，外面有一些东西几乎没有被研究过，我们甚至还没有好的程序来研究它。但如果我们都坐下来一起推理，我们可能可以从中得出一些道理。外星人、火星、时间旅行。听众打电话来谈论影子人，还有那个叫做“老太婆”的食尸鬼，当他们睡觉时坐在他们的胸口上。
But there are ground rules. Art lets the callers discuss whatever they want as long as they follow some system of logic and can back up their claims with a little evidence, with some kind of facts, or at the very least, a coherent story. If not, well, there's going to be trouble.
但有一些基本规则。阿特允许打电话的人讨论任何他们想讨论的事，只要他们遵循某种逻辑系统，并能用一点证据、某种事实，或者至少是一个连贯的故事来支持他们的主张。如果不是，好吧，那会有麻烦的。
East of the Rockies, you're on the air.
落基山脉以东，你在直播中。
Hello, Art.
你好，阿特。
Hello.
你好。
My name is Carl.
我叫卡尔。
Hi, Carl.
你好，卡尔。
I am the Antichrist.
我是敌基督。
Really? How can you be sure, Carl?
真的吗？你怎么能肯定，卡尔？
I was born with six fingers on each hand.
我每只手生下来就有六根手指。
Well, that's still-- that doesn't nail it right there. I mean, it is unusual, Carl. But that doesn't mean you're the Antichrist. There's a lot--
嗯，那还是——那并没有直接说明。我的意思是，这很不寻常，卡尔。但这并不意味着你是敌基督。有很多——
I understand that.
我明白。
OK, what else?
OK，还有别的吗？
I sent--
我发了——
No, wait, wait, wait, Carl. What else?
不，等一下，等一下，卡尔。还有别的吗？
So much more, Art.
还有更多，阿特。
Well, fantastic claims require fantastic evidence.
嗯，奇妙的主张需要奇妙的证据。
I understand that. Let me make a statement to you and to the audience.
我明白。让我对你和听众发表一个声明。
What would that be?
那会是什么？
I am going to save at least one third of the life on this planet.
我要拯救这个星球上至少三分之一的生命。
That doesn't sound like an Antichristy sort of thing.
那听起来不像敌基督做的事。
I understand that.
我明白。
You've got to understand that what you say is held somewhat suspect based on the fact that you've announced yourself as the Antichrist.
你必须明白，基于你自己宣布是敌基督的事实，你所说的话是受到怀疑的。
I certainly do.
我当然明白。
All right, thank you very much. And West of the Rockies, you are on the air. Hello.
好了，非常感谢。落基山脉以西，你在直播中。你好。
Hey, Art, how are you?
嘿，阿特，你好吗？
In the Coast to Coast universe, nearly everyone shares some basic assumptions. We know that aliens exist because so many people call up and talk about seeing them. And if aliens exist, then there has to be a shadow government covering up the aliens. And if the shadow government exists, who is controlling it? Well, that's what we're trying to find out. Ghosts exist too. Also, life after death and reincarnation and time travel and prophecy.
在《Coast to Coast》的世界里，几乎每个人都分享一些基本假设。我们知道外星人存在，因为很多人打电话来谈论看到他们。如果外星人存在，那么就一定有一个影子政府掩盖外星人。如果影子政府存在，谁在控制它？好吧，那就是我们试图发现的。鬼魂也存在。还有死后生命、轮回、时间旅行和预言。
One night, a truck driver called in and said he'd eaten at a '50s style truck stop in Ohio that was filled with pretty waitresses and good food. And then when he tried to go back a few weeks later, it was gone. Not torn down, it had never existed. Art sounded like he'd heard that one before. All he said was, phantom truck stop-- the way you'd say the Eiffel Tower, like we all know what that is-- and then went on to the next caller.
一天晚上，一个卡车司机打电话说他在俄亥俄州的一个 50 年代风格的卡车休息站吃过饭，那里满是漂亮的侍应生和美味的食物。然后当他几周后试图回去时，它消失了。不是拆除了，它从未存在过。阿特听起来好像以前听过这个。他只说了，“幻影卡车休息站”——你叫埃菲尔铁塔的方式，就像我们都知道那是什么一样——然后转到了下一个打电话的人。
Much of the data presented on the show falls into the category of experiments that would be difficult for other scientists to reproduce. For example, the recording of hell. Someone sent Art this tape, which was supposedly recorded by scientists who were mining in Siberia. They drilled down nine miles until they smashed through into earth's hollow core. They measured the temperature at 2,000 degrees. And then they dropped down a super-sensitive microphone to listen to the tectonic movements. But they accidentally recorded the moanings of souls in hell. In case you've ever wondered what that sounds like, here it is.
节目中呈现的大部分数据属于其他科学家难以重复的实验类别。例如，地狱录音。有人寄给阿特这个磁带，据说是科学家在西伯利亚开采时录制的。他们向下钻了九英里，直到钻入地球的中空核心。他们测得温度为 2000 度。然后他们放下了一个超灵敏的麦克风来听构造运动。但他们意外地录下了地狱中灵魂的呻吟。万一你想知道那听起来像什么，就在这里。
[SOUND OF MOANINGS]
[呻吟声]
So Art plays this tape on the air, and people call in to discuss the breakthrough because there are questions of methodology to be discussed. They're not saying, well, maybe hell doesn't exist, or even if hell exists, it's probably not in the center of the earth, or it would be easy for anyone to fake this. They're discussing the logistics of drilling a nine-mile hole and then dangling a microphone into it. The sound quality of this next clip isn't the greatest.
所以阿特在直播中播放了这个磁带，人们打电话来讨论这个突破，因为有方法论的问题需要讨论。他们不是说，“嗯，也许地狱不存在，或者即使地狱存在，它可能不在地球中心，或者任何人伪造这个都很容易”。他们正在讨论钻一个九英里的洞然后把麦克风垂进去的后勤工作。下一个片段的音质不是最好的。
Now look, I'm not a geologist. But in my opinion, if you drilled nine miles down and you came to a pocket that was 2,000 degrees, you're talking about molten rock.
看，我不是地质学家。但在我看来，如果你钻了九英里深，并且进入了一个 2000 度的空腔，你在谈论的是熔岩。
Virtually.
几乎是这样。
And aren't you going to create a volcano? Now, what I'm thinking is--
难道你不会制造一个火山吗？现在，我在想的是——
But they didn't mention, in this story, pressure. They mentioned a horrid little being that came flying out. Then they mentioned the drill bit turning wildly, and they mentioned a high temperature.
但在这个故事里，他们没提到压力。他们提到了一个飞出来的可怕的小生命。然后他们提到了狂转的钻头，他们提到了高温。
But they also mentioned that they lowered a microphone into it.
但他们也提到他们把麦克风垂了进去。
That's right.
没错。
OK, that's a pretty long extension cord. But anyhow--
OK，那是一根很长的延长线。但不管怎样——
Not unreasonable. It could be done. Who says they lowered the microphone to the final depth? And so they may have lowered it just low enough to get the sounds.
并非不合理。这是可以做到的。谁说他们把麦克风垂到了最终深度？所以他们可能只是把它垂得足够低以获得声音。
OK, granted.
OK，承认。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I have an open mind.
我思想开放。
When I think about it, one of the really surprising things about Coast to Coast is how little disagreement there is. You turn on the radio any time of day, and people are arguing about politics or sports or whatever. When there are disagreements on Coast to Coast , they're about whether aliens are truly from another world or are simply human beings traveling through time to harvest our DNA. Or whether the pyramids were built by people from other planets or if they were built by giants.
当我想起它时，《Coast to Coast》真正令人惊讶的事情之一是分歧是多么少。你随时打开收音机，人们都在争论政治或体育或别的什么。当《Coast to Coast》上有分歧时，它们是关于外星人是否真的是来自另一个世界，还是仅仅是穿越时间来采集我们 DNA 的人类。或者金字塔是由来自其他星球的人建造的，还是由巨人建造的。
I think, just from listening every night, the sheer volume of it, four hours of Coast to Coast whether I'm awake or asleep, I've totally stopped being skeptical about it. Now I just let the ideas wash over me like chemtrails.
我想，仅仅是每晚倾听，纯粹的音量，四个小时的《Coast to Coast》，无论是醒着还是睡着，我完全停止了对此的怀疑。现在我只是让这些想法像化学航迹一样冲刷着我。
You know when jets fly over and you can see the vapor trail, the misty exhaust line that goes away after a few minutes? Those are called contrails. Well, chemtrails look the same, but they hang in the atmosphere for much longer. According to a Canadian journalist, chemtrails are a government-sponsored climate modification experiment. Basically, military jets are spraying large amounts of microscopic particles into the atmosphere to counteract global warming.
你知道喷气式飞机飞过时你可以看到蒸汽尾迹，几分钟后消失的朦胧排气线吗？那些叫凝结尾迹。好吧，化学航迹看起来一样，但它们在大气中停留的时间长得多。根据一位加拿大记者的说法，化学航迹是一项政府赞助的气候改造实验。基本上，军用喷气机正在向大气中喷洒大量微小颗粒以抵消全球变暖。
When I first heard about chemtrails, I thought, quartz particles suspended in midair to reflect light and heal the ozone layer? That sounds pretty far-fetched. But then guests and callers kept bringing it up, and I heard about it so much, it just became part of my normal life. Then NASA just released a study saying that contrails may be affecting climate change. And now, I can't look up into the blue sky without thinking about chemtrails.
当我第一次听到化学航迹时，我想，悬浮在半空中的石英颗粒用来反射光线并治愈臭氧层？听起来很牵强。但后来嘉宾和打电话的人不断提到它，我听到的太多了，它就成了我正常生活的一部分。然后 NASA 刚发布了一项研究，说凝结尾迹可能正在影响气候变化。现在，我无法看向蓝天而不想到化学航迹。
On Fridays, George Noory, the other host of Coast to Coast , does open lines. And sometimes he asks for stories from people around a particular theme. Last week, the theme was "I was cursed," and he got calls from all over. One guy talked for a long time about these creatures that were following him. A woman called and said she'd been cursed for over 20 years by a former roommate, and that everything had gone terribly for her until she'd hired a good witch to remove the curse. And then George got this call from Bob, east of the Rockies. On any other radio show, Bob would just be another sad story about depression, and the toll it takes on you. But on Coast to Coast , if you're depressed and have had a hard time, then you must have been cursed.
在星期五，《Coast to Coast》的另一位主持人乔治·努里进行开放热线。有时他要求人们讲述关于特定主题的故事。上周，主题是“我被诅咒了”，他接到了来自各地的电话。一个人谈论了很久关于那些跟踪他的生物。一个女人打电话说她被前室友诅咒了 20 多年，在她雇了一个好女巫解除诅咒之前，一切对她来说都变得非常糟糕。然后乔治接到了落基山脉以东的鲍勃的这个电话。在任何其他广播节目中，鲍勃只是另一个关于抑郁症及其带来的代价的悲伤故事。但在《Coast to Coast》上，如果你抑郁且经历过困难，那你一定是受到诅咒了。
I wasn't going to call in tonight, but after hearing some of the stories and-- I just started going, wow, a lot of that stuff has happened to me. And I've got to tell you George, I credit you and your show for saving my life.
我今晚本来不打算打电话，但在听到一些故事后——我只是开始想，哇，很多事情都发生在我身上。我不得不告诉你，乔治，我归功于你和你的节目拯救了我的生命。
What happened?
发生了什么？
Well, I'm just one of these people who has this dark cloud over him. And I almost decided that I was going to just do it all in.
嗯，我只是这些人中的一个，头上有一片乌云。我差点决定要彻底了结它。
No.
不。
Because things just weren't making sense. And I just couldn't seem to get a break anywhere. And I've listened to your show and listened to the people. And there was just such a connection there.
因为事情就是没有意义。我似乎在任何地方都找不到出路。我听了你的节目，听了人们的讲述。那里有一种联系。
At 1:00 in the morning, I understand what he means. We're all up in the middle of the night, we can't sleep. We're worried about things we can't really do anything about. It's all just so much easier to deal with if there's a reason. We're cursed, or it's the shadow people, or demons, or chemtrails. If there's some bigger, powerful, controlling force, then everything makes sense. It's easier to stop worrying. It's easier to go to sleep.
在凌晨 1 点，我明白了他的意思。我们都在半夜醒着，我们睡不着。我们担心我们真的做不了什么的事情。如果有一个理由，处理这一切就容易多了。我们被诅咒了，或者是影子人，或者是恶魔，或者是化学航迹。如果有一个更大的、强大的、控制力，那么一切就都有意义了。停止担心就容易多了。入睡就容易多了。
Tell me about the cloud. Is it still there?
跟我说说那片云。它还在吗？
The cloud? It seems to be dissipating a little bit because I'm beginning to understand about the world around me a lot more.
那片云？它似乎正在消散一点，因为我开始更多地了解我周围的世界。
Good for you.
为你感到高兴。
Because there was just so much I didn't understand. But now I do because there's more to this world than we really can see with just our five senses.
因为有太多我以前不了解的。但现在我了解了，因为这个世界不仅仅是我们能用五个感官看到的那样。
Brent Runyon lives in Cape Cod and is the author of the memoir, The Burn Journals , which will come out this September.
布伦特·鲁尼恩住在科德角，是回忆录《燃烧日记》的作者，该书将于今年 9 月出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Will Reichel.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、莎拉·柯尼格和丽莎·波拉克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特运营我们的网站。托德·巴克曼和威尔·雷切尔提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have Public Radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们节目的音频，在那里他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至是《纽约时报》，都在 audible.com。本节目由公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia. Every time he wanders by my office or I pass him in the hall, I can hear him mumbling to himself.
WBEZ 的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。每次他经过我的办公室或我在走廊经过他时，我都能听到他在自言自语。
OK, I just got a big chill. I have a definite male presence right there. I don't want anybody to move.
OK，我刚才感觉到一阵恶寒。我感觉到那里有一个明确的男性存在。我不希望任何人动。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。